Imagine living in a world where everyone looks vaguely familiar, but you never know for certain exactly who anyone is. Your old classmates, your co-workers, your friends, and even your family members, all can appear at first glance to be friendly strangers who seem to know you. That's what life is like for people with prosopagnosia or face blindness. Historically, the disorder was thought to be rare, but more recent research suggests it may affect as many as one in 50 people. Last year, Sadie Dingfelder found out she was one of them. Sadie is a former colleague of mine. She used to be an editor at APA's magazine,
想象一下生活在这样一个世界里：每个人看起来都似曾相识，但你永远无法确定对方到底是谁。你的老同学、同事、朋友，甚至家人，乍一看都像是认识你的友好陌生人。这就是面容失认症（prosopagnosia），也就是“脸盲症”患者的生活状态。过去，人们认为这种疾病很罕见，但最近的研究表明，每50个人中就可能有一人受其影响。去年，萨迪·丁费尔德（Sadie Dingfelder）发现自己就是其中之一。萨迪是我以前的同事。她曾是美国心理学会（APA）杂志的编辑，
and I later hired her to be editor of our website. After a lifetime of thinking that there was something just a little bit different about her brain, Sadie took part in a study at Harvard Medical School that finally gave her some clarity about her condition. She wrote about the experience for the Washington Post magazine. So what is it like to have prosopagnosia? and what have psychologists and other scientists learned about the causes of face blindness?
后来我聘请她担任我们网站的编辑。萨迪一直觉得自己的大脑有些与众不同，在哈佛医学院参加了一项研究后，她终于对自己所患的疾病有了清晰的认识。她为《华盛顿邮报》杂志撰文记录了这段经历。那么，患有面容失认症是什么感觉？心理学家和其他科学家对面盲症的成因又有哪些了解？
Can it be treated? If so, how? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. If you enjoy speaking of psychology, the conversation doesn't have to stop when the podcast is over. Get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the podcast. the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names, discussing
它能治愈吗？如果能，该怎么治？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。如果您喜欢《心理学谈话》，对话不必在播客结束后就停止。注册参加美国心理学会2020年虚拟大会，即可低价无限次观看数百个关于播客的视频，了解心理学的最新动态。先从我们精选的视频开始，这些视频汇集了心理学界的大咖，讨论
such topics as COVID-19, racism, and stigma. Or let your curiosity take over and use our on-demand library to explore any topic. Go to convention.a.org.org slash podcast. That's convention.a.a.org slash podcast. We actually have two guests today. Joining Sadie and me is Dr. Joseph Dugutus, a neuroscientist and experimental psychologist at Harvard Medical School and the Boston VA. He studies the neuroscience of face blindness and has developed treatment programs to help those with face blindness improve their ability to recognize faces. He runs the study that Sadie participated in and was the person who confirmed herself diagnosis. Welcome to speaking of psychology. Thanks. Thanks for having me. Yeah.
诸如新冠疫情、种族主义和污名化等话题。或者，您可以跟随好奇心，利用我们的点播库探索任何主题。请访问 convention.apa.org/podcast。网址是 convention.apa.org/podcast。今天我们有两位嘉宾。除了萨迪和我，还有哈佛医学院和波士顿退伍军人事务部的神经科学家兼实验心理学家约瑟夫·德古蒂斯（Joseph DeGutis）博士。他研究面盲症的神经科学，并开发了治疗方案，帮助面盲症患者提高面部识别能力。他负责萨迪参加的那项研究，也是确认她自我诊断的人。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。是的。
Sadie, let's start with the question that I posed in the intro. What is it like to have prosopagnosia? When you look at people, what do you see? Yeah, well, a lot of people think that face-blind people maybe just see a blur where faces. That's definitely not true. I have good visual acuity. My problem is I just don't remember faces. Like the second I'm looking away from them, they're gone from my memory.
萨迪，让我们从我在开场白中提出的问题开始。患有面容失认症是什么感觉？当你看着别人时，你看到了什么？是的，很多人认为脸盲症患者看到的脸可能是一片模糊。这绝对不是真的。我的视力很好。我的问题是我记不住脸。比如，我刚把目光从他们身上移开，他们就从我的记忆中消失了。
And I was kind of astounded to find out that everyone else has like an almost photographic visual memory for faces specifically. Dr. Dugutus, what does the research tell us about why prosopagnosix can't do this thing that other people do so effortlessly recognizing and remembering faces? Is the problem memory, perception, or perhaps both? Yeah, that's a great question. I think that the research shows right now and our kind of recent results have found kind of two different maybe subtype. So one, more of a perceptual subtype where you can't tell faces apart that are right in front of you. And then there's also this more of this memory component where, you know,
我非常惊讶地发现，其他人对人脸竟然有近乎照相般的视觉记忆。德古蒂斯博士，研究告诉我们，为什么面盲症患者无法像其他人那样毫不费力地识别和记住人脸？问题出在记忆、感知，还是两者兼而有之？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我认为目前的研究表明，我们最近的结果发现了两种不同的亚型。一种是感知亚型，即你无法分辨眼前的人脸。另一种是记忆成分，你知道，
kind of like you were saying in the intro, prosopagnosics can have this vague kind of feeling, but they don't have this kind of rich, robust kind of once they see somebody where they where all this other information about the person comes back to them automatically. And, you know, people are remarkably good at faces. And I think that this is one of the things that it could be, you know, from an evolutionary standpoint, it looks like, you know, the face maybe exploded in the genetic kind of variation. And in some ways, I think a lot of, you know, we capitalize on this and we are able to kind of recognize individuals by their faces. And in other species, like, for instance, penguins, they don't have quite a, you know, maybe people are like, well, if I were a penguin, I could recognize penguin faces. But their faces don't, they don't vary as much.
就像我在开场白中说的那样，面盲症患者可能会有一种模糊的感觉，但他们没有那种丰富、稳固的体验，即一旦看到某人，关于这个人的所有其他信息就会自动浮现。而且，你知道，人们在识别面孔方面非常出色。我认为这可能与进化有关，看起来面孔在遗传变异方面可能出现了爆发式增长。在某种程度上，我认为我们利用了这一点，能够通过面孔识别个体。而在其他物种中，比如企鹅，它们并没有……也许人们会说，如果我是企鹅，我就能认出企鹅的脸。但它们的脸并没有那么大的差异。
So the human face is exploded in variability. And, you know, our brains have kind of maybe evolved to capitalize on that. And I think with prosopagnosics, yeah, there's these very subtle deficits that maybe accumulate and they're not able to capitalize on all this variability. And one of the remarkable things, too, I want to just say is it's a pretty specific disorder. I think we keep as scientists, we see that these people are, you know, have normal in, and sometimes above average, like intellectual abilities and other abilities. So it's like one of these developmental disorders that's very, seems pretty, like very specific,
所以人类的面孔在变异性上出现了爆发。我们的大脑可能已经进化到利用这一点。我认为对于面盲症患者来说，确实存在一些细微的缺陷，这些缺陷可能会累积，导致他们无法利用所有这些变异性。我还想说的一件了不起的事情是，这是一种非常特殊的疾病。作为科学家，我们发现这些人拥有正常的，有时甚至是高于平均水平的智力能力和其他能力。所以这是一种看起来非常特殊的发育障碍，
you know, in comparison to other developmental disorders. So it seems like this vision and visual memory specific disorder. What's actually happening in brains like Sadie's when they see people's faces? what have you learned from brain imaging studies about where this disorder originates in the brain? Yeah, so I think one of the things that we're finding is that there's kind of these two perceptual processes. And I know, I know Sadie's results, so I'm not going to totally go into her results. But basically, a lot of prosopagnosics have trouble with putting all the parts of the face together into a complete whole. So this is something we do automatically. You can call it
与其他发育障碍相比。所以这似乎是一种特定的视觉和视觉记忆障碍。萨迪这样的人在看到人脸时，大脑里到底发生了什么？从脑成像研究中，你们了解到这种疾病在大脑中的起源是什么？是的，我认为我们发现的一件事是存在两种感知过程。我知道萨迪的结果，所以我不会完全深入讨论她的结果。但基本上，许多面盲症患者在将面部的所有部分组合成一个完整的整体时存在困难。这是我们自动完成的事情。你可以称之为
holistic processing or gestalt processing, and it's something that is very fast and automatic. The other thing that we're finding is that a lot of the prosopagnosics have particular trouble with kind of being sensitive to the eye region. So the eyes hold a lot of information with regard to identity. So that's something that, you know, one of the main mechanisms of like these perceptual deficits are both maybe a combination of these feature, lack of feature sensitivity and then a difficulty with putting the face together into a hole. So that's on the perceptual side of things. And then on the more on the memory side, I kind of, it's kind of this type of memory that we call recollection memory. So recollection memory,
整体加工或格式塔加工，这是一种非常快速且自动的过程。我们发现的另一件事是，许多面盲症患者在对眼部区域的敏感度方面存在特别的困难。眼睛包含大量关于身份的信息。所以，这些感知缺陷的主要机制之一可能是缺乏特征敏感性，以及难以将面部组合成一个整体。这是感知方面的问题。而在记忆方面，我称之为“回想记忆”。所以回想记忆，
again, it's like kind of taking a face and making all these associations with all this other information. And usually when you see a face, all this extra semantic information, like their name, their job when you last saw them, comes flooding back without any effort. Now, when a prosopagnosic and I think Sadie can say more about this, sees a face, they don't get this flood of information. A lot of times they're met with this kind of vague sense of knowing. And we call that, you know, familiarity memory. And sometimes, and that was kind of coined back in the 80s as the butcher on the bus phenomenon when you see somebody out of context, let's say your butcher or a barista that you frequent and you can't place who it is. Now, prosopagnosis, I'd love to hear more
同样，它就像是获取一张脸，并将所有这些关联与所有其他信息联系起来。通常当你看到一张脸时，所有这些额外的语义信息，比如他们的名字、工作、你上次见到他们的时间，都会毫不费力地涌现出来。现在，当一个面盲症患者——我想萨迪可以对此多说一点——看到一张脸时，他们不会得到这种信息流。很多时候，他们面对的是一种模糊的熟悉感。我们称之为“熟悉记忆”。这在80年代被称为“公交车上的屠夫”现象，即你在特定环境之外看到某人，比如你的屠夫或你常去的咖啡师，却想不起他是谁。现在，关于面盲症，我很想听听
of what Sadie says. This might happen with very, very familiar people. Whereas with people who don't have prostapagnosia, this may just happen with a new acquaintance. Does this happen to you, Sadie? Do you have a butcher on the bus? Oh, yeah. I have a lot of trouble identifying people out of context. But I have a lot of trouble identifying people who are right in their normal context, too. I was just on the elevator in my apartment building, and this woman was like, oh, hey, Sadie, and I had no idea she was. We were both wearing masks. And I'm like, I'm sorry, I have no who are. She's like, oh, I cat sat for you, like, last week. And I was like, oh, cool. So, yeah, she was in my building, and I did not recognize her. But the masks make it really hard.
萨迪怎么说。这种情况可能发生在非常非常熟悉的人身上。而对于没有面容失认症的人来说，这可能只发生在新的熟人身上。萨迪，这种情况发生在你身上吗？你有过“公交车上的屠夫”时刻吗？哦，是的。我在特定环境之外识别他人时非常困难。但我在正常环境中识别他人时也很有困难。我刚才在我公寓楼的电梯里，有个女人说：“哦，嘿，萨迪。”我根本不知道她是谁。我们都戴着口罩。我说：“对不起，我不知道你是谁。”她说：“哦，我上周帮你照看过猫。”我说：“哦，酷。”所以，是的，她在我的楼里，但我没认出她。口罩让识别变得非常困难。
That has to be tough, not only for people like Sadie, but what happens to children at various levels of development? I mean, if we're going around wearing masks for the next year or more, Dr. Deguus, is that going to have any effect on their development, do you think? You know, I don't think we know, but I mean, I think that the face recognition system needs to have a lot of input and a lot of different faces. And actually, they found that some people that grow up in kind of smaller towns, even, you know, may not be as good at face recognition than people who grow up in larger cities that have more exposure. And there's a little bit, there's some evidence that there may be these kind of critical periods for face recognition where you, you, you know, maybe you can differentiate all faces, and this is something related to the other race, effect, where you may be able to differentiate all faces of all different ethnicities. And then after a while, you're, you kind of, whatever ethnicity you're most exposed to, you get better at that. So there may be these critical periods.
这对像萨迪这样的人来说一定很艰难，但对于处于不同发育阶段的儿童来说会发生什么呢？我的意思是，如果我们接下来一年或更长时间都要戴口罩，德古蒂斯博士，你认为这会对他们的发育产生任何影响吗？你知道，我不认为我们知道，但我认为面部识别系统需要大量的输入和许多不同的面孔。事实上，他们发现一些在小城镇长大的人，甚至可能不如在大城市长大、接触面孔更多的人擅长面部识别。有一些证据表明，面部识别可能存在关键期，在这个时期，你也许能区分所有面孔，这与“异族效应”有关，即你可能能够区分所有不同种族的面孔。过了一段时间，你接触最多的种族，你就会变得更擅长识别。所以可能存在这些关键期。
I hope, I think it's an interesting question if this is affecting development or if we can kind of rely on, you know, neuroplasticity or the ability for the brain to kind of reorganize and recover. But I do think just seeing, you know, part of the face may disrupt this holistic processing and kind of putting all the face together. So it could. I wonder if, like, all the kids are on TikTok, right? I wonder if exposure to faces that are flattened on a screen can make up for it. I guess we need research.
我希望，我认为这是一个有趣的问题，这是否会影响发育，或者我们是否可以依赖神经可塑性，即大脑重组和恢复的能力。但我确实认为，只看到面部的一部分可能会破坏这种整体加工，以及将整个面部组合在一起的过程。所以这可能会有影响。我很好奇，所有的孩子都在玩TikTok，对吧？我想知道，接触屏幕上扁平的面孔是否能弥补这一点。我想我们需要研究。
It's really not fair to ask you, Dr. Deguda, since you're not a developmental psychologist. Yeah, I mean, I think that, yeah, I think people are still seeing a lot of faces on TV and on the screen. I mean, it could be slightly different than interacting with people in a more kind of face-to-face. But actually, some of the prosopagnosis kind of have mentioned that faces seem flat to them. And I guess I just wanted to ask you, Sadie, is that something? something that you, I mean, it's hard to kind of have insight into this, but, you know, do you see faces as being flat? Do you see them, or do you see them as being kind of three-dimensional? I have nothing really to compare it to because I see everything as flat because my eyes are not
问你这个问题真的不公平，德古蒂斯博士，因为你不是发展心理学家。是的，我的意思是，我认为人们仍然在电视和屏幕上看到很多面孔。我的意思是，这可能与面对面互动略有不同。但实际上，一些面盲症患者提到面孔对他们来说似乎是平面的。我想问你，萨迪，这是你……我的意思是，很难对此有洞察力，但你看到的面孔是平面的吗？你看到它们是三维的吗？我没有什么可以比较的，因为我看到的一切都是平面的，因为我的眼睛没有
aligned correctly. So I only use one at a time and do not have binocular vision, which is another thing I kind of discovered as an adult and didn't realize. It was very exciting to figure out like why I could never catch a fly ball. It wasn't entirely my fault. And is that unusual that this non-stereo vision would be associated with face blindness? Yeah. People have found that difficult, you know, like with eye movement kind of issues like stripismus or amblyopia, that that prosopagnosics have a higher incidence. Now people haven't exactly figured out why, but that is something that we've noticed and other labs have noticed. that maybe, so maybe kind of using your eyes together to create a 3D faces is an important
正确对齐。所以我一次只用一只眼睛，没有双眼视觉，这是我成年后才发现的另一件事，之前我并不知道。弄清楚为什么我永远接不住飞球真是太令人兴奋了。这并不完全是我的错。这种非立体视觉与脸盲症有关联，这不寻常吗？是的。人们发现，像斜视或弱视这样的眼球运动问题，在面盲症患者中的发病率更高。现在人们还没有完全弄清楚原因，但这是我们和其他实验室注意到的事情。所以，也许用双眼共同创造三维面孔是
aspect of, you know, face perception and recognition. Some of us, Sadie probably included, learned about face blindness by reading a fascinating essay in 2010 in the New Yorker magazine by the British neurologist Dr. Oliver Sacks. He described a life in which he avoided other people and not even recognizing his own face in the mirror. Dr. Degutis, how common is that type of coping. Well, and I think that there's, we kind of see a couple different variants of, of coping strategies. And some, you know, so one of the things we're looking into is, is whether prosopagnosics
面部感知和识别的一个重要方面。我们中的一些人，可能包括萨迪，是通过阅读英国神经学家奥利弗·萨克斯（Oliver Sacks）博士2010年在《纽约客》杂志上发表的一篇引人入胜的文章了解到脸盲症的。他描述了一种回避他人、甚至在镜子里认不出自己脸的生活。德古蒂斯博士，这种应对方式有多普遍？嗯，我认为我们看到了几种不同的应对策略。其中之一是我们正在研究的，即面盲症患者
are more like introverted or extroverted. And we didn't find anything there. But, but I think what, what some prosopagnosics do is they just go out there in the world and they're nice to everybody. And they're just overwhelmingly smiling and, and, and, you know, in a couple of the prosopegnoissex do, Peknozics that I studied was at the University of California, Berkeley, I just remember seeing them from like 100 yards away, and they're just beaming a smile and looking around at everybody. And I think that that's something that, I mean, it's probably a lot of work to do that. But I think that's one of the strategies is like you just kind of have to pretend like you know everybody until proven otherwise.
是更内向还是外向。我们没有发现任何相关性。但我认为一些面盲症患者所做的是，他们只是走进这个世界，对每个人都很友好。他们总是笑容满面，你知道，我研究过的几个面盲症患者，在加州大学伯克利分校，我记得从100码外看到他们，他们只是笑容灿烂地看着每个人。我认为这是一种策略，虽然这样做可能需要付出很多努力。但我想这是一种策略，就是你必须假装认识每个人，直到被证明不是这样。
But I think maybe some other prosopagnosics, you know, feel more anxious. about, you know, social settings, interactions, and that might not be for everybody. But I kind of, you know, I defer to Sadie because I know that sometimes, you know, you've mentioned that you might use a little bit of that strategy. Yeah, I definitely, and deep, like, very friendly to everyone all the time. And that's totally a coping mechanism because, like, anyone could end up being, like, a good friend. So you don't want to miff or, you know, you don't want to hurt someone's feelings. So you're just like, anyway, this strategy at one time caused me to talk to a woman who quickly turned out to be a total stranger on the street.
但我认为也许其他面盲症患者对社交场合和互动感到更焦虑，这可能并不适合所有人。但我还是听听萨迪的意见，因为我知道有时你提到过你可能会使用一点这种策略。是的，我绝对会，对每个人都非常友好。这完全是一种应对机制，因为任何人都有可能成为好朋友。所以你不想冒犯，或者不想伤害别人的感情。所以你只是……无论如何，这种策略有一次导致我与街上的一个女人交谈，结果发现她完全是个陌生人。
And I tricked her into thinking that she knew me. That's great. And I mean, we talked for like five minutes. And then I'm like, okay, got to run. And, like, she looked so confused. And I kind of felt happy to, like, have inflicted my confusion on someone else. But it wasn't very nice. But it wasn't intentional until I realized.
我骗她以为她认识我。那太棒了。我们聊了大约五分钟。然后我说，好吧，得走了。她看起来很困惑。我有点高兴能把我的困惑强加给别人。但这不太好。但在我意识到之前，这不是故意的。
No, Sadie, I remember a few years ago I was walking in front of the building for lunch. And you came up the street and I said, hey, Sadie. And you stopped and you said hello. But then you said, oh, I was afraid I might run into some people from work if I walked past here. And I didn't know. And maybe you didn't even know at that time that you had face blindness, but you covered very well. Yeah, well, that's the thing about developmental disabilities is that you just grow up coming up with lots of clever strategies and you have no idea that there's strategies and you just assume everyone else is doing the exact same thing. So I really thought I was like maybe a little bad with faces, but like completely on the normal curve.
不，萨迪，我记得几年前我走在楼前去吃午饭。你从街上走过来，我说，嘿，萨迪。你停下来说了你好。但随后你说，哦，我担心如果我从这里走过，可能会遇到一些同事。我不知道。也许那时你甚至不知道自己有脸盲症，但你掩饰得很好。是的，这就是发育障碍的特点，你只是在成长过程中想出了许多聪明的策略，而你根本不知道那是策略，你只是假设其他人也在做同样的事情。所以我真的以为我可能只是不太擅长认脸，但完全在正常范围内。
And then it turns out I am really quite exceptionally bad. And proud of it. I think there is actually, you know, in our testing of people, there's quite a range. Like some people will say they're really suffering, like that it hurts their employment, opportunities, that it really affects their social lives, that it really creates a lot of social anxiety and difficulties. But then there's other people that, you know, maybe are, you know, have figured out ways to compensate. I think making a very kind of like specific context. I know we we gave a talk at the
结果我竟然异常地差。而且以此为荣。我认为实际上，在我们的测试中，存在相当大的范围。有些人会说他们真的很痛苦，比如这损害了他们的就业机会，严重影响了他们的社交生活，造成了很大的社交焦虑和困难。但也有其他人找到了补偿的方法。我认为创造一个非常具体的环境。我知道我们在
Google headquarters and we had a couple of prosopagnosics there and they said that they had very specific people they interacted with and they knew where everybody sat and they and they only and so they kind of set up their lives in a way that that would help them recognize people and they didn't have these situations where they were thrown into a situation where they had to recognize everybody out of context or on the fly or so um but i think you know some people you know this is just like an annoyance and other people really can make a big difference in in their in their life and socializing i actually kind of think that it gave me a little bit of um a a superpower in terms of like since i've been practicing talking to strangers my entire life um as a reporter it is very easy
谷歌总部做过演讲，我们有几个面盲症患者在那里，他们说他们有非常特定的互动对象，他们知道每个人坐在哪里，他们只和这些人互动，所以他们以一种有助于识别人的方式安排生活，他们不会陷入那种必须在特定环境之外或临时识别所有人的情况。但我认为，对有些人来说，这只是一个烦恼，而对另一些人来说，这确实会对他们的生活和社交产生很大影响。我实际上认为这给了我一点“超能力”，因为自从我练习与陌生人交谈以来，我的一生……作为一名记者，与人建立联系非常容易。
to like connect with people. And I think a lot of even like professional reporters get anxiety about talking to strangers, just walking up to a stranger and talking to them. And I have no problem doing that because I have been doing that my entire life. Can we talk about treatments? I know, say, to you've had some treatments. Dr. DeGutis, maybe you can explain some of what you have done and how well these treatments work. Well, I guess I guess the first thing I want to say before, the treatment side of it,
我认为很多专业记者在与陌生人交谈时也会感到焦虑，只是走近一个陌生人并与他们交谈。我这样做没有任何问题，因为我一生都在这样做。我们可以谈谈治疗吗？我知道，萨迪，你接受过一些治疗。德古蒂斯博士，也许你可以解释一下你所做的一些工作以及这些治疗的效果如何。嗯，我想在谈到治疗方面之前，我想说的第一件事是，
is that, and this is something that, you know, Sadie, you can talk about because you've written about, but I think that just raising awareness, I think if people know about this, I mean, this is one of these things where you grow up in, you know, when you grow up, you know about how good you are at math and you know how good you are at sports and you know how good you are. But in some ways, like, a lot of people, you know, they may kind of think they have a problem with face recognition, but it's not something that is easy. You can say, well, maybe I just don't pay attention or I'm kind of lazy. I don't know. I don't know what it is. So I guess just raising awareness, having people know
这是萨迪你可以谈论的，因为你写过关于它的文章，但我认为仅仅提高意识，如果人们知道这一点，我的意思是，这是你成长过程中知道自己数学有多好、运动有多好、能力有多好的一件事。但在某种程度上，很多人可能认为他们有面部识别问题，但这并不是一件容易的事。你可以说，也许我只是不注意，或者我有点懒。我不知道。我不知道那是什么。所以我想仅仅提高意识，让人们知道
if they have this thing. And I think that has allowed people to either, you know, have a better understanding of, you know, oh, I can tell somebody, oh, I have prosopagnosia, and this is, and this is what happens. So like, you know, destigmatizing when you, when you miss somebody from, and misrecognize somebody or you walk right past them, you're like, hey, sometimes I'm going to just walk right past you and it's not because I'm aloof and I don't care. I just have post ofagnosia. So that is like a big thing to raise awareness and get the kind of word out. And I think it really can, has given people a lot of relief and insight into their lives. And yeah, maybe if, say, if you want to talk about that before, and I can, we have training
他们是否有这种疾病。我认为这让人们能够更好地理解，比如，我可以告诉别人，哦，我有面容失认症，这就是发生的事情。所以，当你错过某人、认错某人或直接从他们身边走过时，消除污名化，你可以说，嘿，有时我会直接从你身边走过，这不是因为我冷漠，也不是因为我不关心。我只是有面容失认症。所以提高意识并传播这个消息是一件大事。我认为这确实给了人们很大的解脱和对生活的洞察。是的，也许如果萨迪你想在之前谈谈这一点，我可以……我们有培训
programs. I'll talk, I can talk about that. But I just also want to say to you to chime in about how powerful that has been. Oh, yeah. Like, I mean, it felt like a central mystery in my life was suddenly sort of cleared up. Like, I used to be worried that I was very self-centered because I could never remember people's names or, um, if there was something, you know, something like wrong with me at, like, the spiritual level or something. And it was really fun just to learn that like my fusiform face area is not working very well. And, um, you know, it doesn't, it doesn't like reflect poor. early on me as a human being. Which is a part of the brain that we haven't really talked about, the fusiform face area.
项目。我会谈谈，我可以谈谈这个。但我只是也想让你插话谈谈这有多大的力量。哦，是的。这感觉就像我生命中的一个核心谜团突然被解开了。我过去常常担心自己非常以自我为中心，因为我从来记不住别人的名字，或者如果有什么……在精神层面或其他方面有什么问题。得知我的梭状回面孔区（fusiform face area）工作得不太好，这真的很有趣。而且，你知道，这并不反映我作为一个人的好坏。这是我们还没有真正谈论过的大脑部分，梭状回面孔区。
Yes. Apparently, that's where you recognize faces in your brain. What are the treatments and how do they work? So right now, there's a couple different avenues that people have explored. But one is to do this kind of computer-based training, and that's focused on either kind of like, you know, matching faces or getting better at kind of being sensitive to the configuration of features. So that's something that there's been maybe four or five studies that have looked at that and had shown some benefit. We're also looking into some memory
是的。显然，这就是你在大脑中识别面孔的地方。治疗方法是什么？它们是如何工作的？所以现在，人们探索了几种不同的途径。一种是进行这种基于计算机的训练，重点是匹配面孔或提高对特征配置的敏感度。所以这是已经有四五项研究关注过并显示出一定益处的事情。我们也在研究一些记忆
training that targets kind of improving recollection memory, which is, you know, trying to be, take a more effortful approach to, you know, taking a face and just adding all this information and trying to, you know, kind of actually create a narrative around the face and process the face more deeply and make more connections to things like, oh, you know, how does the face make you feel? How extroverted or introverted is the face? You know, and these are kind of judgments that Postpagnosics can do. They can kind of say, ooh, yeah, this face is a true. or I think this space is trustworthy or and we're trying to actually, you know, have the face information and also these other, you know, things like their name and their profession,
训练，旨在提高回想记忆，也就是尝试采取一种更费力的方法，获取一张脸并添加所有这些信息，尝试实际上围绕这张脸创造一个叙事，更深入地处理这张脸，并与事物建立更多联系，比如，哦，这张脸让你有什么感觉？这张脸有多外向或内向？你知道，这些是面盲症患者可以做的判断。他们可以判断，哦，是的，这张脸是……或者我认为这张脸值得信赖。我们正试图实际上让面部信息以及其他信息，比如他们的名字和职业，
be processed more deeply, making like a story about the face in order to try to get that, that feeling of recollection, that, that automatic kind of like, oh, okay, that's, that's, that's Sadie and I recognize her and I know that she's, you know, here, all this kind of other contextual and semantic information comes back. So another another kind of avenue that people have explored is actually oxytocin, which is this kind of neuropeptide that they showed that actually you can, if you squirt a little bit of oxytocin, nasal oxytocin, that prosopagnosics got better at face recognition temporarily. And it looks like it may be the mechanism is by focusing more on the eye region. So, but I guess the training is still a little bit at its
被更深入地处理，围绕这张脸编一个故事，以试图获得那种回想的感觉，那种自动的，哦，好的，那是萨迪，我认出她了，我知道她在这里，所有这些其他背景和语义信息都会涌现出来。所以人们探索的另一个途径实际上是催产素，这是一种神经肽，他们证明了如果你喷一点催产素，鼻内催产素，面盲症患者的面部识别能力会暂时提高。看起来其机制可能是通过更多地关注眼部区域。所以，但我认为训练仍然处于
infancy. It's still one of these things that were, I think what we've proven is that, you know, for years and years, people thought face recognition was kind of set in stone. And if you damage the face recognition system or it never developed properly, that it was, that was that. But I think what we've shown is that it can be, you know, rehabilitated or enhanced. Now, we're still talking about, you know, modest improvements. So I don't think, I think the things I want to caution against is this is not like a cure. It's definitely an experimental treatment that it works for some people and it doesn't work as well for others. Sadie, have you tried the oxytocin?
起步阶段。这仍然是我们已经证明的事情之一，多年来，人们认为面部识别是固定不变的。如果你损坏了面部识别系统，或者它从未正常发育，那就是那样了。但我认为我们已经证明它可以被康复或增强。现在，我们谈论的仍然是适度的改善。所以我不想说的是，这不像是一种治愈。这绝对是一种实验性治疗，对某些人有效，对其他人效果没那么好。萨迪，你试过催产素吗？
No, no one's given me oxytocin, but I have totally tried if someone wants to. since I'm over. You got to go back to Harvard. How sticky is the training? Do you have to, is it sort of like going to the gym? Do you have to keep doing it all the time? Yeah. I mean, I think also, you know, Sadie, you can answer this question,
没有，没人给我催产素，但如果有人愿意，我绝对会尝试。既然我还在。你得回哈佛。这种训练的持久性如何？它就像去健身房吗？你必须一直做吗？是的。我的意思是，我认为，萨迪，你可以回答这个问题，
but I think it's something where you do it for, you know, a couple of months. And then it usually lasts for, you know, two or three months. And then it kind of, then you kind of go back to the way that you were processing faces before. Sadie, I don't know. What was it like for you when you kind of went through the training and then? It was interesting. I think, yeah, after the, at first, like, it felt like sort of a developed. Like, I felt like after the training, I was like a little bit better.
但我认为这就像你做几个月。然后它通常会持续两三个月。然后它会……然后你会回到你之前处理面孔的方式。萨迪，我不知道。当你经历训练时，那是什么感觉？这很有趣。我想，是的，起初，它感觉像是一种发展。我觉得训练后我好了一点。
And then, like, in the weeks following, I kind of got even better. And then it's been, like, sort of a long decline since then. Though you've retested me, so you can tell me if that's accurate. But in terms of, like, it being a modest. improvement, I think that I, like, for instance, I recognized a random dude in a coffee shop and for who lives in my building. And I, like, I had to ignore him because I didn't feel like talking to him. And I think it might have been like the first time in my life I intentionally ignored someone. So it's not necessarily like something I want to do all the time. So I didn't
然后，在接下来的几周里，我变得更好了。从那以后，它经历了一段漫长的衰退。虽然你重新测试了我，所以你可以告诉我这是否准确。但就它是一种适度的改善而言，我认为，例如，我在咖啡店认出了一个随机的家伙，他住在我楼里。我不得不忽略他，因为我不想和他说话。我想这可能是我一生中第一次故意忽略某人。所以这不一定是我一直想做的事情。所以我没有
do any boosters. Well, Dr. Togoodis, let me ask you, you published a story. where you looked at whether people self-reports about their face recognition ability matched up with whether they actually had prosopagnosia. What did you find? Do most people with prosopagnosia realize they have it? And should we be testing kids? Is this something that we should be adding to the standard battery of tests that we give to children? Yeah.
做任何加强训练。好吧，德古蒂斯博士，让我问你，你发表过一个故事，你研究了人们关于面部识别能力的自我报告是否与他们是否真的患有面容失认症相符。你发现了什么？大多数面盲症患者意识到自己患有这种病吗？我们应该测试孩子吗？这是我们应该添加到我们给孩子做的标准测试组合中的东西吗？是的。
So I think that this idea that a lot of people are walking around and they have no idea they of prosopagnosia. I think there's always in, you know, this, I, you know, I think that we're finding that that's, um, people may think that they're like, man, I think I'm below average. I think this idea that you have no idea that you have any face recognition deficits is false. So most of our prosopagnosics
所以我认为，很多人四处走动却根本不知道自己有面容失认症的想法……我认为总是……我认为我们发现这并不完全正确。人们可能认为他们是……天哪，我想我低于平均水平。我认为你根本不知道自己有任何面部识别缺陷的想法是错误的。所以我们的大多数面盲症患者
that come to the lab or go through the screening. A lot of it, a lot of times they say like, well, um, I think I'm bad at faces, but then we're like, oh, you're, you're really, really bad and they're like oh i didn't realize i was like in the point oh oh one percentile of of people but um i think people do uh become aware of this and usually it's it's around like junior high or high school that people kind of first become aware that this is a this is a thing and um so i think this is and that's also when these social interactions are really important and they may have had these kind of salient events in their lives that happened during that time.
来到实验室或通过筛查。很多时候他们说，嗯，我想我不擅长认脸，但随后我们说，哦，你真的非常非常差，他们说，哦，我没意识到我处于人群的0.01%的水平。但我认为人们确实意识到了这一点，通常是在初中或高中左右，人们第一次意识到这是一回事。所以，我认为这是……这也是社交互动非常重要的时候，他们可能在那段时间里经历过生活中一些显著的事件。
So I think people do, they have some insight into their face recognition abilities. But yeah, I think testing children is a great kind of direction that the field needs to go into. It has been tough to kind of get at this because the memory system is developing. Who knows if this is just going to be like, you know, in a few years if this is something that is going to kind of, they're going to grow out of it. I mean, face recognition itself doesn't really peak until your early 30s. So, but I think there are some challenges with identifying children. But if we could identify children, that would be great because I think some of the suffering and some of the difficulties that Procepegnosics report in like middle school in high school, it would be really. really wonderful to try to avoid. I mean, middle school and high school is rough for everybody,
所以我认为人们确实对自己的面部识别能力有一些洞察。但是，是的，我认为测试儿童是该领域需要发展的伟大方向。这很难实现，因为记忆系统正在发育。谁知道这是否只是……你知道，几年后这是否会……他们会摆脱它。我的意思是，面部识别本身直到30岁出头才真正达到顶峰。所以，但我认为识别儿童确实存在一些挑战。但如果我们能识别出儿童，那就太好了，因为我认为面盲症患者在初中和高中报告的一些痛苦和困难，如果能避免，那将是非常非常美妙的。我的意思是，初中和高中对每个人来说都很艰难，
but I think it's particularly hard for prosopagnosis. Is there a genetic component to this? Sadie, you were apparently born with this. Are there others in your family who you think maybe have this? Yes. I mean, I think my uncle has face blindness. He disagrees, but I remember once, I mean, one time we were at Thanksgiving and he said to my brother, like, Oh, are you Sadie's roommate or something? And Saul's like, no, I'm your one nephew who you'd known since I was born. And Aaron was like, oh, anyway, my uncle was like, oh, yeah, right. So I just think, yeah, I don't know why anyone would be in denial about it.
但我认为这对面盲症患者来说尤其困难。这有遗传成分吗？萨迪，你显然是天生就有这个。你的家人里还有其他人你认为可能有这个吗？是的。我的意思是，我认为我叔叔有脸盲症。他不同意，但我记得有一次，我们在感恩节，他对我的兄弟说，哦，你是萨迪的室友吗？索尔说，不，我是你从我出生起就认识的侄子。亚伦说，哦，无论如何，我叔叔说，哦，是的，没错。所以我只是认为，是的，我不知道为什么有人会否认它。
It's a pretty cool disorder to have. We're in such good company. We've got Oliver Sacks. We have, what's the chimpanzee researcher? Oh, Jane Goodall. Jane Goodall. Yeah. Yeah, I was really surprised to very.
这是一种很酷的疾病。我们有很好的同伴。我们有奥利弗·萨克斯。我们有……那个黑猩猩研究员是谁？哦，珍·古道尔（Jane Goodall）。珍·古道尔。是的。是的，我真的很惊讶。
read about that. I mean, there she was working with all these chimps that you had to recognize. I mean, Sadie, do you recognize your dog? Oh, actually, you're a cat person. Well, I'm also a birdwatcher, right? And so there's not a lot of, it's, I guess I don't have to recognize individual birds, though, very often. They're all little brown birds. You know, also, the craziest one is Chuck Close, who draws those huge, beautiful portraits. And of course he's obsessed with faces because there's such a puzzle.
读到那个。我的意思是，她当时和所有这些必须识别的黑猩猩一起工作。我的意思是，萨迪，你认得你的猫吗？哦，实际上，你是爱猫人士。嗯，我也是个观鸟者，对吧？所以没有太多……我想我不必经常识别单个鸟类。它们都是棕色的小鸟。你知道，最疯狂的是查克·克洛斯（Chuck Close），他画那些巨大、美丽的肖像。当然，他痴迷于面孔，因为它们是一个谜。
I think it's really cool that he channeled that through his art. So overall, Sadie, do you think knowing this is what you have has changed your life? You know, yeah, definitely. I wish I'd known as a kid, honestly, because I had so much trouble making friends. And I just assumed it was because I was weird, which isn't incorrect. But knowing the specifics would have been very helpful because I could have, you know, maybe I could have like used pictures. Later in college, before I knew I was faceblind, I did make flashcards for myself of everyone who lived in my dorm. It didn't actually help that much, though, so I don't know.
我觉得他通过艺术引导这一点真的很酷。所以总的来说，萨迪，你认为知道这是你所患的疾病改变了你的生活吗？你知道，是的，绝对。老实说，我希望我小时候就知道，因为我在交朋友方面遇到了很多困难。我只是假设这是因为我很奇怪，这并不完全错误。但知道具体情况会非常有帮助，因为我可以……也许我可以……使用图片。后来在大学里，在我知道自己脸盲之前，我确实为我宿舍里的每个人制作了抽认卡。但实际上并没有太大帮助，所以我不知道。
But I do. I think knowing about yourself is always powerful. And it helps you sort of work around your issues and no, not to, well, and then I can just tell people too. I tell people in faceblind all the time. I don't know if they believe me. So sometimes I say, Google it. It's real. Well, Dr. Daggutis, there may be some people listening to this thinking.
但我确实认为，了解自己总是强大的。它能帮助你绕过你的问题，而且……好吧，我可以告诉别人。我一直告诉别人我脸盲。我不知道他们是否相信我。所以有时我说，去谷歌一下。这是真的。好吧，德古蒂斯博士，可能有一些听众在想，
I have trouble recognizing faces. I wonder if I might have prosopagnosia. Where should they go to find out? Yeah, so there's a, I think, I mean, one of the, we just started another study to look at more of these memory problems and also to train. memory and focus on memory, that's at faceblind.harvard.edu. And there's also some great resources at faceblind.org. So those would be two kind of good websites to start with. And you can do some self-tests, and we can send you some other tests to take and also give you some feedback.
我有识别面孔的困难。我想知道我是否可能患有面容失认症。他们应该去哪里寻找答案？是的，所以有一个……我认为，我的意思是，我们刚刚开始了另一项研究，以观察更多这些记忆问题，并进行训练。记忆和专注于记忆，网址是 faceblind.harvard.edu。faceblind.org 上也有一些很棒的资源。所以这两个网站是很好的起点。你可以做一些自我测试，我们可以给你发送其他测试，并给你一些反馈。
So I think that this is something we're trying to get the word out and trying to get, you know, with the pandemic, we're also making everything online. So I think we can get a lot of really useful information and do some of these training studies online. So that would be a recommendation. And are you looking for more subjects for your research? Yeah. Yep. So we're looking for more participants and then also to, you know, we're also happy just to kind of say,
所以我认为这是我们正在努力传播的消息，并且试图……随着疫情的到来，我们也在把一切都搬到网上。所以我认为我们可以获得很多非常有用的信息，并在线进行一些这些训练研究。所以这是一个建议。你们还在为你们的研究寻找更多的受试者吗？是的。是的。所以我们正在寻找更多的参与者，而且我们也乐于……只是说，
oh, here's, you know, here's how I perform. and here's what's kind of happening in my daily life and we can kind of give you some, I think one of the useful things that we can provide is we've tested a lot of people with face blindness or prosopagnosia, and we can say, oh yeah, this is, you're right in the middle, this is what everybody is kind of reports,
哦，这是我的表现，这是我日常生活中发生的事情，我们可以给你一些……我认为我们可以提供的一件有用的事情是，我们测试了很多患有脸盲症或面容失认症的人，我们可以说，哦，是的，这……你就在中间，这就是每个人报告的情况，
or we can also say, oh, you know, in our history of testing a couple hundred people with face blindness, we've never heard of that. So I think that sometimes is useful. to know, like, even if you're a prosopagnosic, am I like a typical prosopagnosic? Or am I kind of like, you know, a little quirky or different? But I think that what that's one of the things I think we've, we've also found that people have enjoyed knowing like a little bit more about like, oh, I report all these experiences or I have this really, you know, my perception is fine, but I just
或者我们也可以说，哦，你知道，在我们测试几百名脸盲症患者的历史中，我们从未听说过这种情况。所以我认为这有时很有用。知道这一点，即使你是一个面盲症患者，我是典型的面盲症患者吗？还是我有点古怪或与众不同？但我认为这是我们发现人们喜欢了解更多的事情之一，比如，哦，我报告了所有这些经历，或者我有这个……我的感知很好，但我只是……
have this memory problem. So I don't, you know, then we can say, oh, yeah, that's about, you know, 45% of prosopagnosics. So I think it's been really useful for people to know that they're not alone. There's a lot of people like them. And also to see like, oh, yeah, like there's this fits in with a lot of the other things people are experiencing. Yeah, it's so fun to get on the prosopagnosic Facebook group because I feel like it's like a lot of people who had the same childhood as mine.
有这种记忆问题。所以我不，你知道，然后我们可以说，哦，是的，大约有45%的面孔失认症患者是这样。所以我认为让人们知道他们并不孤单真的很有用。有很多像他们一样的人。而且也能看到，哦，是的，这与人们经历的其他许多事情是一致的。是的，加入面孔失认症的Facebook群组真的很有趣，因为我觉得里面有很多和我童年经历一样的人。
And, you know, someone will write like, does anyone else like only make friends with very distinctive looking people. And I was like, oh my God, all my friends had blue hair or, you know, and it's fun to find out you're not alone. It's kind of, it helps with the feeling of isolation, living in a world where everyone kind of looks like a stranger. I'm just curious. How did you land on oxytocin as a treatment? So the oxytocin treatment wasn't our lab that kind of spearhead that. That was Sarah Bate and her colleagues. But oxytocin has kind of been thought of this as this kind of trust neuropeptide that is about, you know, facilitating social bonds and things like that. It also has, it may have a slight dark side to it too where maybe you facilitate in-group bonds,
而且，你知道，有人会写道，有没有人也只和长相非常有特色的人交朋友？我就想，天哪，我所有的朋友都留着蓝头发，或者，你知道，发现自己并不孤单真的很有趣。这在某种程度上，有助于缓解那种生活在一个每个人看起来都像陌生人的世界里的孤独感。我只是好奇。你是怎么想到用催产素作为治疗方法的？所以催产素治疗并不是我们实验室率先提出的。那是Sarah Bate和她的同事们做的。但催产素一直被认为是一种信任神经肽，它与促进社会纽带等有关。它也可能有一点阴暗面，也许你会促进群体内的纽带，
but not out-group bonds. So that's another conversation. But I think that oxytocin has thought of, they've looked on some of these genes that are related to oxytocin. And that's kind of, there's some candidate genes that may be involved in both, you know, autism and prosopagnosia. So there's a little bit of a higher incidence of prosopagnosa, prosopagnosia, and people who are on the autism spectrum. So this is, you know, so I think this idea of that oxytocin is kind of this social neuropeptide, it may have to do with kind of forming social bonds or, you know, face processing. And that's kind of why they, yeah, so it's also kind of this idea of like trust and and maybe engagement with faces. So it's kind of trying to improve attention and engagement with faces was the idea.
但不是群体外的纽带。所以那是另一个话题了。但我认为催产素被认为是，他们研究了一些与催产素相关的基因。而且，有一些候选基因可能同时涉及自闭症和面孔失认症。所以自闭症谱系障碍患者中面孔失认症的发病率略高。所以，我认为催产素作为一种社会神经肽的观点，可能与形成社会纽带或面部处理有关。这就是为什么他们，是的，所以这也与信任以及可能与面部的互动有关。所以这是一种试图改善对面部的注意力和参与度的想法。
Given that it's situated in a physical part of the brain, has anyone looked at a possible surgical intervention? I think the surgical. So yeah, I guess I just to quickly kind of go over the, In the brain, I think the brain with faces is so one of the things about why faces are so much so studied in neuroscience is you have, you know, and this is back in the 90s by Nancy Kenwisher and MIT and others, you know, across in many different labs. They found this, there's this little region about the size of the tip of your pinky that just really responds to faces more than anything other, any other kind of visual input. And, you know, this fuse, they call it the fusiform face area. Now, they've also found that there's this one back a little further in the visual processing stream called the occipital face area.
鉴于它位于大脑的物理部分，有没有人研究过可能的各种手术干预？我认为手术。所以是的，我想我只是快速回顾一下，在大脑中，我认为大脑处理面部信息的研究之所以在神经科学中如此受重视，是因为你有，你知道，这是90年代Nancy Kenwisher和麻省理工学院以及其他人在许多不同实验室的研究。他们发现，有一个大约小指尖大小的区域，它对人脸的反应比任何其他视觉输入都要强烈。而且，你知道，这个梭状回，他们称之为梭状回面孔区。现在，他们还发现视觉处理流中更靠后一点的地方还有一个枕叶面孔区。
And there may be even subcomponents of the fusiform face area. But it's these kind of modular, it's probably one of the only systems in the brain that is organized in a modular way. Meaning, like, you kind of have these little nodes that do most of the work. So the interesting thing is, like, all of our prosopagnosics have these. regions. It's not like there are holes there in their brain where you'd think of face area. Their brain regions light up to faces. Now, we're finding that their face areas are not as selective, meaning they don't prefer faces over other stimuli and other visual objects as much as someone without prosopagnosia. And we even find that their face areas may be a little
甚至可能还有梭状回面孔区的子组件。但这些是模块化的，它可能是大脑中唯一以模块化方式组织的系统。意思是，你有一些执行大部分工作的小节点。所以有趣的是，我们所有的面孔失认症患者都有这些区域。并不是说他们的大脑里有空洞，你以为会有面孔区的地方。他们的大脑区域在看到人脸时会亮起。现在，我们发现他们的面孔区选择性没那么强，意思是他们不像没有面孔失认症的人那样，对面孔的偏好超过其他刺激物和其他视觉对象。我们甚至发现他们的面孔区可能稍微
thicker, which means that, like, early in development, your cortex is really thick. And actually, as you think thinner is, is, is worse. But sometimes in the brain, thinner and more dense is kind of how it means that you're making more connections. And so we kind of find that some of the, the developmental prosopagnosics have thicker face areas and not as well connected to other brain regions, like your hippocampus, which is involved in like memory. So in these, and these anterior temporal lobes which are involved in like retrieving somebody's name and how you know them. So it is, it's this really interesting thing where the, you know, the developmental prosopagnosis agnosics we've studied have all of the structures there. They're just not optimized. They're not
厚一点，这意味着，在发育早期，你的皮层真的很厚。实际上，你认为越薄越糟糕。但有时在大脑中，更薄、更致密意味着你正在建立更多的连接。所以我们发现一些发育性面孔失认症患者的面孔区更厚，而且与其他大脑区域（如涉及记忆的海马体）的连接不够好。还有这些涉及检索某人名字和你是如何认识他们的前颞叶。所以这是一个非常有趣的事情，你知道，我们研究的发育性面孔失认症患者拥有所有的结构。它们只是没有被优化。它们没有
as connected. They're not as working as efficiently. They're not as like selective. And so I think like, you know, you brought up a surgical intervention. I think, sometimes people have tried to do brain stimulation, non-invasively. They haven't kind of opened up somebody's skull to do something really invasive. Yeah, that's pretty radical. Yeah, that's pretty radical. But it's actually, and there hasn't been much positive results with the non-invasive brain simulation, but they found that these patients who have, you know, one of the things they wanted to do is figure out is the face area of really, you know,
连接得那么好。它们的工作效率没有那么高。它们的选择性没有那么强。所以我认为，你知道，你提到了手术干预。我认为，有时人们尝试过非侵入性的大脑刺激。他们并没有打开某人的头骨去做一些非常侵入性的事情。是的，那太激进了。是的，那太激进了。但实际上，非侵入性大脑刺激并没有太多积极的结果，但他们发现这些患有癫痫的病人，你知道，他们想做的一件事是弄清楚面孔区是否真的
important and necessary for face processing and face recognition. So in this person who had epilepsy, they put electrodes in their face area. And when they stimulated the face area, they reported that as they were looking at somebody's face, it like transmogrified and kind of melted and changed. And so this is really, I mean, it's fascinating. And it really made everybody believe like, oh, this isn't just, you know, like some kind of epiphenomenon. This little brain region is very much at the hub of what we're doing with faces and face recognition. And, you know, these epilepsy, this epilepsy patient would report that you just change to somebody else. As soon as they, they stimulated this brain area, they said, oh, you became somebody else. So I don't know if
对人脸处理和人脸识别很重要且必要。所以在这个患有癫痫的人身上，他们在面孔区植入了电极。当他们刺激面孔区时，他们报告说，当他们看着某人的脸时，它好像变形了，融化了，改变了。所以这真的，我的意思是，这太迷人了。它确实让每个人都相信，哦，这不仅仅是某种附带现象。这个小脑区确实处于我们处理面孔和人脸识别的核心位置。而且，你知道，这个癫痫病人会报告说你变成了别人。一旦他们刺激了这个大脑区域，他们就说，哦，你变成了别人。所以我不知道
they're going to try that treatment for prosopagnosia anytime soon, but it's very fascinating. And it really shows how specialized these brain regions are. And, And also why this is a very kind of, in terms of a developmental disorder, this is a very specialized disorder. A lot of developmental disorders like ADHD or even autism spectrum disorders, like lots of the brain region, like many, many brain regions have been implicated. With prosopagnosia, it's like we're dealing with these little small, specific, selective areas. And I think that's also from a neuroscience perspective, why it's been so fascinating to understand. And if we can actually improve face recognition, how do these little small nodes change? Are they making more connections?
他们是否很快会尝试那种治疗面孔失认症的方法，但这非常迷人。它确实显示了这些大脑区域是多么专业。而且，这也是为什么从发育障碍的角度来看，这是一种非常特殊的障碍。许多发育障碍，如多动症甚至自闭症谱系障碍，涉及很多大脑区域，许多许多大脑区域都受到牵连。而对于面孔失认症，我们处理的是这些小而具体、有选择性的区域。我认为从神经科学的角度来看，这也是它如此迷人的原因。如果我们真的能改善人脸识别，这些小节点会如何改变？它们是在建立更多的连接吗？
Are they getting thinner? Are they activating in a more selective manner? So this is one of the things that we can use this disorder to help us understand a lot more about what they call neuropasticity, which is kind of how the brain changes with experience. And so as you can tell, we're pretty excited about this possibility. But again, we're still scratching the surface. This is still the beginning. You know, you don't need brain surgery.
它们是在变薄吗？它们是在以更有选择性的方式激活吗？所以这是我们可以利用这种障碍来帮助我们更多地了解所谓的神经可塑性的事情之一，也就是大脑如何随着经验而改变。所以你可以看出，我们对这种可能性感到非常兴奋。但同样，我们仍然只是触及了表面。这仍然是开始。你知道，你不需要大脑手术。
All you need is like facial recognition glasses, right? Like the technology already exists. It's being used in people's home security systems. But for privacy reasons and because everyone thinks it's creepy, they won't put it in glasses but it's my dream I wish that like if you had a if you like could prove that you
你所需要的只是人脸识别眼镜，对吧？技术已经存在了。它正被用于人们的家庭安全系统中。但出于隐私原因，而且因为每个人都觉得它很诡异，他们不会把它放在眼镜里，但这是我的梦想，我希望如果你能证明你
were face blind or something you could get these you'd have magic glasses that would tell you who everyone is and you're I think that'd be amazing okay that leads me to the last question I want to throw to you Sadie which is if if you could cure this would you do so
是面孔失认症患者或者类似的情况，你就能得到这些，你会拥有神奇的眼镜，能告诉你每个人是谁，我觉得那太棒了。好的，这引出了我想问你的最后一个问题，Sadie，如果如果你能治愈它，你会这样做吗
or are you so accustomed to living with face blindness that you couldn't imagine living any other way oh my God I love to cure it. I mean, I would really like to see what faces look like to everyone who isn't faceblind. I get the feeling that there's actually a qualitative difference. And similarly, I would like to have binocular vision too. Like, I would like to be able to see things in three dimensions. So I think that, I mean, I do think it's been a huge part of my sort of personality growing up, but I'm 40 or something. I'm 41, I guess. And anyway, and I feel like, you know, I've fully capitalized on my, my mind.
还是你已经习惯了带着面孔失认症生活，以至于无法想象以其他方式生活？天哪，我很乐意治愈它。我的意思是，我真的很想看看那些不是面孔失认症的人眼中的人脸是什么样的。我有一种感觉，实际上存在质的差异。同样，我也想拥有双眼视觉。比如，我想能够看到三维的东西。所以我认为，我的意思是，我确实认为这是我成长过程中个性中很大的一部分，但我已经40岁左右了。我想我41岁了。总之，我觉得，你知道，我已经充分利用了我的大脑。
old brain, my brain, and why not try something new now? Well, thank you for joining me today. It's been really interesting. I really enjoyed it. And Sadie, it was great to see you again. It's been a while. Yeah. Yeah. Thanks so much. All right. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingofpsychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology.
旧大脑，我的大脑，为什么现在不尝试一些新的东西呢？好吧，谢谢你今天加入我。这真的很有趣。我很喜欢。Sadie，很高兴再次见到你。已经有一段时间了。是的。是的。非常感谢。好的。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是Speaking of Psychology。
psychology all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiyan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
psychology是一个词，在apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condiyan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。